see i love your career your career makes
a lot of sense to me
you were like really young when you
moved to la right where were you 18
just after college i was 22. right and
the career was kind of you know
[ __ ] i'm schlepping along here nothing's
happening he's bartending
yeah you were bartending yes i heard the
other people in the restaurant who
worked at the restaurant didn't like you
because you wouldn't give the waiters
free drinks
absolutely true you were like a really
honest bartender i was so young howard
that i didn't even know to be dishonest
about anything
right i had no idea no clue
like you didn't feel your co-worker you
didn't feel peer pressure at all when
you were a bartender to help the waiters
out
to be honest and you were like listen
[ __ ] i'm the bartender and i can't
give you free drinks
the same part of me that wouldn't be
freak give out free drinks wouldn't call
him by an [ __ ] either
very polite like no no i can't you
didn't buy this drink i was genuinely
naive
right i got fired from that bartending
job not because
i was so honest although i had i'm sure
nobody had my back in there because i
wouldn't give them you know the rest
why did you get fired from the
bartending job i think i subconsciously
wanted i i i not only
left the restaurant the gate up right
and the door wide open but the cash
register opened
with about 600 in it really and just
wandered out of the restaurant and had
my shift the next day
and the owner of the place is smiling
and waving me over come here
come here come here stupid exactly right
is you any idea what you did last night
i'm like no
you really have no idea like no he's and
he explained to me what i did
and he said so i'm gonna have to let you
go and i said i don't suppose you give
me another chance and he literally
laughed in my face like you found that
hilarious
right he just cost me 600
well actually the money was still in
there believe it or not just the idea
that you would leave it a lot
prove that you were irresponsible little
did he know you were saving him money at
the bar
well he said no he knew that he said i
tell you what i'll give you a
recommendation anywhere because you're
as honest as the day is long with the
exact phrase you used yeah
said but you know get out of here
because you're just too and then i
called my dad
they were still pay phones then howard
there was one
he said you know and he was a great guy
because he didn't particularly want me
to do this
right but he said well you know you want
to be a bartender you want to be an
actor
right so go be an actor oh they really
believed in you
he believed in that i should try it